what's up everybody it's warren and the
official teaser trailer for marvel's
eternals
just came out released by marvel studios
it's two minutes and seven seconds long
let's go ahead and watch it for the
first time
these are people or
is that number the celestials
[Music]
they look awesome oh
we have watched
unguided we have helped them progress
wow throughout the years
until now
[Music]
oh you need
oh my god
[Music]
wow
[Music]
thank you all so now that captain rogers
and iron man are both gone
anything's
[Music]
oh man they look awesome
wow let me go back to that shot where
they're all just standing there
that's amazing the visuals in this movie
are going to be
absolutely insane as you can already
that's just the teaser we get a little
bit of
kind of an understanding what's going on
here so the eternals were kind of sent
to
monitor the human race they're sent
there by the celestials who actually
made them
the celestial gods it's unclear on
whether they know that
or not it does seem like they know their
purpose says they kind of helped
humanity at first and then they've
never interfered until now now
that until now could be
what's happening during infinity war end
game or it could be something after
involving celestials we don't really
know that much yet but
one of the biggest questions was where
were they during the videos end game
if their job is to kind of protect
humanity and the world
what were they doing this entire time so
it could be that but it could be an
all new bigger threat that we're not
really aware of yet
but uh one thing for sure is they look
awesome
this trailer was awesome this movie is
going to be visually insane the cast is
absolutely incredible
um so i'm gonna start on my breakdown
let me know what you think
about this teaser in the comments down
below full official
two minute seven second teaser uh i
thought it was awesome but let me know
what you think be sure to subscribe to
get the trailer breakdown it's gonna be
up
in a couple hours or so as always thank
you all so much for watching woof